المصري يتخلى عن مزاعيمه تجاه السعوديه
ويعترف انه لم يناقش اصلا سعر صفقه تحويل
تسلا الى شركه خاصه مع صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه خمس ساعات قضاها ماسك امام محكمه
سان فرانسيسكو الفدراليه اشتكى خلالها من
التعب وقله النوم ولم تخلو من السخريه
والضحك والاقوال المتضاربه يواجه مسجد
اتهامات بتظليل المساهمين في تسلا باعلانه
في اغسطس 2018 انه امن تمويلا لشراء كامل
اسهم الشركه المدرجه بسعر اعلى من
المتداول في ذلك الحين بنحو 20% حينها كان
يقول ان التمويل مؤمن من صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه السعوديه لكنه الان
يقدم مباريات مختلفه ومتضاربه لاعلانه
السابق اخر هذه المبررات الجديده قوله
للقضاه ملكيه في سبيس اكس وحدها تكفي شعرت
ان تمويل مؤمن
الى شركه خاصه قبل ايام كان محامي قد ساق
ذريعه مختلفه حين اشار الى ان ماسك كان
على تواصل مع رئيس شركه الدل ومستثمرين في
جولنا ساكس وسيرفر
لاقناعهم بتمويل الخطه ماذا قال ردا على
سؤال من محامي انه التقى ممثلين صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه السعوديه في مصنع تسلا
في كاليفورنيا لكنه اقر بصريح العباره ان
سعر الاستحواذ على اسهم تسلا لم تتم
مناقشته خلال الاجتماع محامي المدعين قال
القضاه ان محضر اجتماعي يؤكد ان السعوديين
طلب معرفه المزيد عن ما يدور في راسك
وبالتالي لم يكن هناك اتفاق كما زعم الرجل
سابقا الذريعه الثانيه التي ساقها ماسك
انه لم يجزم في تغريده الشهيره بانه سيحول
الى شركه خاصه بل قلت انني افكر في الامر
اما بخصوص تامين التمويل لذلك فقط كنت
اعبر عن راي شخصي ويبقى يقرر القضاه
التسعه ما اذا كان ماسك قد تعمد تصعيد سهم
تسلى بشكل مصطنع عبر تغريدته المضلله
الجانب الطريف في المحاكمه كان حين سئل
لماذا حدد السهم 420 دولارا لعرض
الاستحواذ على تسلا فحسب استنتاجات هيئه
الاسواق وسرع الامريكيه اختار ماسك هذا
الرقم لانه شائع في ثقافه من يتعاطون
الملكوانا واعتقد ماسك ان تحديد العرض
بهذا السعر سيكون مسحه مضحكه لصديقته في
ذلك الحين الطبع نفى ماسك هذا الاتهام
لكنه لم يمكن يوما حبه